[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur France 24 à la
une ce soir le capitaine Ibrahim Traoré
officiellement désigné chef de l'État au
Burkina Faso une désignation alors que
des manifestations manifestants sont
sortis dans la rue lui a porté leur
soutien parmi les défis qu'il
l'attendent la lutte contre le
terrorisme et l'insécurité alimentaire
reportage dans un instant
la réaction de la famille Lumumba après
la décision de la justice belge la
chambre des mises en accusation de
Bruxelles a décidé de verser au dossier
d'instruction la quasi-totalité des
documents de la commission d'enquête
monnaie il y a 22 ans par le Parlement
fédéral nous serons acquis une chassa
dans ce journal
le procès du massacre du 28 septembre
2009 a été renvoyé au 10 octobre en
Guinée mercredi les débats ont été très
tendus entre les avocats des différentes
parties le compte rendu de notre
correspondant à Conakry à suivre
au Burkina Faso six jours après le coup
d'État qui a renversé le colonel
d'amybal le nouvel homme fort du pays le
capitaine Ibrahim Traoré a été désigné
officiellement en président les défis
qui l'attendent sont nombreux ses
principalement l'échec de son
prédécesseur à instaurer la sécurité
qu'il l'a conduit au pouvoir parmi les
événements déclencheurs l'attaque de
gaskindé ou un convoi de ravitaillement
sous-escort militaire en direction de
Djibo est tombé dans une embuscade
terroriste le bilan fait état de 37
morts 10 jours après les chauffeurs
commencent à témoigner les experts sont
formels la route est trop dangereuse ni
à Masson
il lui aura fallu une dizaine de jours
pour raconter le 26 septembre dernier ce
chauffeur a été attaqué par des
djihadistes dans le nord du Burkina Faso
il faisait partie d'un convoi de
dizaines de camions chargés de vivre
j'ai eu peur mais après c'est passé mais
j'ai eu peur parce que j'ai eu mes
collègues beaucoup mes collègues que je
vois pas d'autres qui sont morts le
convoi était en route pour Jibo une
localité encerclée par les groupes
djihadistes 37 personnes ont perdu la
vie lors de cette attaque selon l'armée
70 conducteurs de camions restent
disparus
sécuriser non c'est-à-dire
on était sous couvert des militaires
mais si les militaires soit il n'avait
pas le matériel adéquat pour nous sauver
bon
vraiment c'est beaucoup de questions
selon ce consultant en sécurité la
violence de l'attaque aurait précipité
le coup d'État quelques jours plus tard
moi je l'appelle l'axe de la mort parce
que c'est un axe qui est entièrement
contrôlé par le groupe par météorisme à
partir de
entièrement contrôlé par les groupes par
météorisme alors donc envoyer et
une telle escorte aussi envoyé les
hommes à l'abattoir et pourquoi 5 jours
après le drame un Pucci militaire le
cinquième en deux ans dans la région
balayait le pouvoir en place à
Ouagadougou énième attaque dans une
région du Sahel meurtrie depuis 10 ans
par la violence djihadiste gaskindé
apparaît comme un nouveau symbole de
l'impuissance des États à sécuriser leur
population
et c'est insécurité a des conséquences
graves sur les populations la ville de
Djibo et sous blocus des djihadistes
depuis le mois de février les habitants
manquent de tout lundi 8 enfants sont
morts de fin dans cette ville c'est
insécurité alimentaire touche d'autres
régions reportages de notre envoyé
spécial au Burkina Faso en
bataille est une déplacée en terre de
Caillard une localité du nord du Burkina
Faso maire de cet enfant elle a dû
quitter sa région natale pour fuir les
attaques djihadistes aujourd'hui elle
peine à nourrir sa famille les denrées
alimentaires sont maigres notamment à
cause de la sécheresse
aujourd'hui encore se nourrir reste une
difficulté parfois nous arrivons à
trouver de la nourriture mais parfois
nous dormons le ventre vide en général
nous arrivons à prendre deux repas par
jour souvent nos enfants pleurent parce
qu'ils ne mangent pas assez mais nous
faisons de notre mieux pour leur trouver
quelque chose à manger
au Burkina Faso les régions sous
influence djihadistes sont soumises à un
blocus il est donc difficile de les
ravitailler pour cette expert la
solution serait de sécuriser les routes
nos attentes c'est de trouver un
mécanisme
bien habilité ou un mécanisme bien
adapté à ravitailler permanent la ville
c'est à dire la levée du blocus parce
que avec le blocus tout est venu de ces
difficultés là seule solution pour
ravitailler certaines villes du pays les
vois aériennes mais certaines ONG jugent
que cela n'est toujours pas suffisant
pour lutter contre la famille selon elle
il faudrait plus de financement nous
avons besoin de
590 millions de dollars pour financer la
réponse humanitaire au Burkina Faso à ce
moment-là
et à ce jour uniquement 88 millions de
dollars ont été mobilisés au Burkina
Faso le taux d'insécurité alimentaire a
presque doublé par rapport à 2021
aujourd'hui c'est plus de 600 000
personnes qui souffrent de famine dans
le pays
on vous parlait hier de ce
rebondissement dans l'affaire Lumumba la
justice belge a décidé de verser au
dossier d'instruction la quasi-totalité
des documents de la commission d'enquête
menée il y a 22 ans par le Parlement
fédéral une décision dans le cadre de
l'enquête déclenchée par la plainte
déposée en 2011 par François Méry
loumumba fils aîné de Patrice Lumumba
notre correspondante à Kinshasa Aurélie
Basara kibangula a pu recueillir sa
réaction
près de 200 cartons de documents vont
être déclassifiés ce sont des
comptes-rendus d'audition faites par le
Parlement belge qui avait mis sur pied
une commission d'enquête parlementaire
sur l'assassinat de Patrice Emery
Lumumba le premier Premier ministre
congolais les témoins de l'époque ont
été auditionnés entre 2000 et 2001 des
auditions menées à huis clos alors pour
la famille avoir accès à ces documents
c'est un nouvel espoir de connaître
davantage les circonstances de
l'assassinat du héros de l'indépendance
congolais
très important très important si on voit
les quantités de la grandeur de dossier
vous comprenez ça peut être aussi l'Inde
intéressant les gens qui ont essayé ils
ont essayé de retarder ou bien de
résister pour donner etc ça montre que
on a peur de quelque chose
ça montre qu'on a peur disons quelque
chose en bref le résultat il est là bien
entendu ça va prendre du temps pour
besoin de la lecture mais c'était un
état étape extrêmement importante vers
la bonne direction l'optimisme de la
famille est toutefois nuancée
car elle de de haut fonctionnaires
belges en poste au moment de
l'assassinat de Patrice Emery Lumumba
ils sont tous les deux encore en vie la
justice belge a estimé que rendre public
leurs auditions porterait atteinte à
leur vie privée alors ici à Kinshasa la
famille Lumumba s'interroge car les
auditions de ces deux témoins clés
pourraient peut-être lever les zones
d'ombre encore nombreuses la Belgique a
reconnu sa responsabilité morale dans
les années 2000 dans la mort de Lumumba
mais jusqu'à ce jour aucune condamnation
n'a été prononcée par la justice
et puis toujours en République
démocratique du Congo 8 militants de la
lucha ont été placés sous mandat d'arrêt
provisoire et conduit à la prison
centrale de roost Churu selon un avocat
ils sont suspectés de troubles à l'ordre
public ils ont été interpellés après
avoir été après avoir tenté d'organiser
un meeting pour dénoncer l'état de siège
qui sévit dans la province du Nord qui
vous depuis mai 2021 il dénonce
également l'occupation de Bouna Ghana
depuis le 13 juin par le M23
le renvoi du procès du massacre du 28
septembre 2009 en Guinée la prochaine
audience est prévue le 10 octobre le
capitaine Moussa Dadis Camara et c'est
quoi accusé comparaissait devant le
tribunal pour entre autres complicité de
meurtre et de viol en masse mercredi les
débats ont été très houleux entre les
avocats des différentes parties la
correspondance à Conakry de ma liste
quitté
l'ancien président le capitaine
monsadadis Camara a laissé éclater sa
colère l'ex chef de la gente guinéenne
dont les avocats veulent demander le
placement en résidence surveillée à
sursauter du siège où il était assis
dans le box des accusés pour exprimer
son mécontentement une réactions pour
dénoncer sa détention à la prison
centrale de Conakry où il est incasséré
depuis le 27 septembre dernier le
président de la courroie a décidé de
reporter l'audience selon lui pour
donner du temps au tribunal d'examiner
les nombreuses exceptions soulevées par
les avocats de la défense qui conteste
toute une partie de cette procédure
judiciaire la décision très attendue du
tribunal concernant la mise en résidence
surveillée ou non de Moussa Dadis Camara
sera rendu le 10 octobre prochain les
avocats de la partie civile ont déjà
exprimé leur opposition à cette demande
des avocats de la défense selon eux au
camp n'inculpé ne devra bénéficier d'un
régime de faveur
direction le Lesotho ou des élections
législatives se tiendront ce vendredi
cette monarchie constitutionnelle
enclavée à l'est de l'Afrique du Sud est
dirigé depuis 10 ans par des
gouvernements de coalition avec un
parlement souvent divisé le récit de
Caroline lambolis
dès premiers ministres systématiquement
chassés avant la fin de leur mandat
c'est l'histoire du lesotot petit
royaume africain dirigé depuis 10 ans
par des gouvernements de coalition à
l'approche des législatives de ce
vendredi certains électeurs espèrent
voir une vague de changement
je voterais et je voterai pour un parti
politique qui remettra le pays en ordre
et qui nous bâtira une économie forte
os devenait il y a un vrai problème de
chômage
il y a de la corruption notre économie
est en baisse donc nous espérons que le
nouveau gouvernement va faire en sorte
que notre économie s'améliore afin que
beaucoup de jeunes qui sont au chômage
puissent trouver du travail
mais d'autres n'y croient pas
pour moi c'est une perte de temps j'ai
bien eu à faire que d'aller voter et
aider les gens à obtenir des postes
politiques et puis après ils le font
rien pour nous
l'actuel Premier ministre moquette si
majoro ne brique pas de mandat sont
partis la convention de tous les bazotto
et le congrès du Lesotho pour la
démocratie deuxième plus grand du pays
ont tous les deux présentés des
candidats relativement jeunes mais la
surprise est plutôt attendue du côté du
parti de la révolution pour la
prospérité lancer il y a environ 6 mois
par le millionnaire samatecané il a fait
fortune dans les mines de diamant et
considéré comme l'homme le plus riche du
Lesotho
on part au Cameroun ou la situation des
journalistes est de plus en plus
précaire certains cumulent jusqu'à 100
000 sans moi pardon d'arrêt de salaire
le Syndicat national des journalistes du
Cameroun est monté au créneau pour
exiger le versement de ses salaires sans
délais voyez ce reportage de Tony
Michael et Stéphane Noah
des journaux à foison le Cameroun en
compte plus de 600 des journaux les plus
fantaisistes au quotidien les plus
sérieux mais tout ça un problème en
commun le paiement des salaires de leur
journaliste la question est encore tabou
mais dans la rédaction de cette radio du
Douala Alphonse a décidé de briser le
silence ce journaliste de 52 ans a
quitté le journal pour lequel il
travaillait il y a un an il réclamait 21
mois d'arriver de salaire à son
employeur qu'il a traînait à
l'inspection du travail je peux pas vous
dire que ce que moi j'ai obtenu c'est
l'équivalent peut-être de sept mois 7 ou
8 mois au trou sur les 21 j'étais
secrétaire la rédaction que j'ai occupé
pendant 11 ans
vous imaginez je n'étais même pas à 150
000 francs de salaire 150 000 francs Cfa
230 euros un salaire dérisoire et des
cotisations sociales quasi inexistantes
une précarité dénoncée par le Syndicat
national des journalistes du Cameroun
les camarades qui nous ont saisi sur des
questions d'ailleurs de salaire il y en
a de 38 mois ce jour-là la prise donc de
l'organisation Marion Aubin met son
collaborateur font le point sur la
situation des arrivées de salaire dans
la profession pour le syndicat la
précarité des journalistes sont salaires
les rend vulnérables aux tentatives de
corruption tout le monde se plaint
aujourd'hui des journalistes à gage tout
le monde se plaint aujourd'hui des
lanceurs d'alerte tout le monde se
plaint aujourd'hui que la qualité de
l'information n'est plus bonne on a plus
de de fake news mais justement parce que
ceux qui sont censés faire ce travail
sont dans des conditions inacceptables
parmi les journaux indexés pour non
paiement des salaires le très réputé
quotidien Le Jour d'amalmana
si ce directeur de publication reconnaît
des retards dans les salaires il met en
cause de l'état catastrophique des
finances d'une presse locale endettée et
en quasi faillite la dette salariale de
la dette sociale qui que je déplore
n'est qu'une partie de la dette parce
qu'il y a la dette vis-à-vis des
imprimeurs et à la vie la dette
vis-à-vis des fournisseurs papier et à
la dette vis-à-vis des propriétaires la
dette loyers une crise salariale dans la
presse qui est loin d'être résolue
malgré les aides de gouvernementales aux
journaux privés qui se sont élevés après
deux 370000 euros l'année dernière
que deviennent les étudiants africains
qui ont fui l'Ukraine au début de la
guerre certains d'entre eux se sont
réfugiés en France mais la protection
temporaire mise en place pour les
Ukrainiens ne s'appliquent pas à eux
aujourd'hui ils continuent de faire face
à de grandes difficultés pour poursuivre
leurs études reportage de Charlotte
ducat
à son arrivée en France brussie a
cherché des études dans le domaine de la
santé aujourd'hui elle s'est finalement
orientée vers une licence de lettres je
voulais faire dans le paramédical donc
nous sommes arrivés ici en France ça
fait comprendre que les étudiants
étrangers qui sortent de l'Ukraine ils
ne peuvent pas faire dans le médical
c'est grâce à cette association qu'elle
a pu recommencer des études elle vient
en aide aux étudiants africains comme
Makaya qui a fui lui créer une depuis le
mois de mars elle cherche à reprendre
ses études de médecine en vain elle
envisage de se réorienter
de le faire parce que je ne vois pas je
vais rester là je vais faire quoi je
vais continuer à me battre continuer à
demander les inscriptions que je suis
sûr qu'on va pas me donner ces étudiants
africains venus du kraine peine à
reprendre leurs études et voient leur
avenir suspendu
Abdelaziz s'est battu pour qu'il
bénéficie de la protection temporaire
mise en place le 5 mars qui concernait
uniquement les Ukrainiens nous avons
donc c'est une forme de discrimination
parce que les gens fuaient la guerre
quand ils arrivent sur les territoires
européens on distingue entre les
Ukrainiens nationalités et ceux qui ne
sont pas et bien progressivement nous
avons pu obtenir des autorités
effectivement que ces jeunes qui étaient
exclusifs puis progressivement
bénéficier d'un certain nombre
d'avancées une circulaire a été mise en
place par le gouvernement le 6 juillet
permettant aux étudiants étrangers venus
du kraine de s'inscrire en études
supérieur mais le bilan émince sur les
336 qui ont fait appel à l'association
seulement 69 ont retrouvé des études
c'est la fin du journal de l'Afrique
rester avec nous l'info continue sur
France 24
[Musique]